does do you guys think body count
matters in the person that you date uh
Plus in the eye date yeah
and in general so I would say no if I'm
not taking her seriously it doesn't
matter okay if I'm taking her seriously
it's I'm not gonna say it's negligible
it doesn't it's not the deciding factor
but it is something that I think
I would think about okay honest okay
what about you
I um for me personally it actually
doesn't matter because I if people don't
want to tell me I'm like cool it's not
it's your past it's your business like
um but I've genuinely had partners that
have had I I have stuck with a guy who
slept with 350 women and that's not a
joke are you refrigerator
I'm a safe girl
um but I've had boyfriends you can't
protect yourself from like HPV are you
in a con you know what I mean like yeah
were you nervous no no because I make
sure that people I'm like hey okay okay
but um I'm like at the end of the day
your past is your past and I'm not very
insecure I'm like in that moment if
you're sleeping with me you may or may
not be thinking about someone else but
but I think I think it matters to other
people so I'm not I'm under no
dissolution that if I say to people like
I've slept with 33 guys then they'll be
like oh you're a hoe and I'm like okay
that's that's your opinion that's that's
cool cool that it doesn't really matter
to me to be honest
what about you
um well
[Music]
I think that
it doesn't like it doesn't I think for
girls that matter it's more than for
guys yeah like I think it's a double
standard but I I think that it should be
a double standard actually yeah yeah why
do you think that because it's easy for
women to get sex it's not easy for men
yeah and and we have like biological
predispositions and I don't think we can
like undo them yeah so
um it's kind of like asking women not to
be attracted to success it's the same
way I think as asking like men not to be
kind of disgusted by a high body count
it's like natural because they wanted to
ensure paternity historically right sure
so part of my I did psychology at Uni
yeah
a degree was a module
Effectiveness and the entire basis was
sex and relationships yeah and it says
that that's it biologically and you see
it in the animal kingdom that men will
go for quantity women will go for
Quality yeah yeah so if you've got a
high body count men are like surely not
all of these men are high quality men
yeah but that is discounting evolution
and discounting
female sexual pleasure like I don't
think with men a lot of the time because
they're good guys I speak with men
because I'm like I want to get laid Yeah
and
actually to be fair I'm like trying to
cut back back on that but
[Music]
um yeah I get that I get that a lot of
guys are like even though they happily
sleep with like a lot of people and it's
because yeah it's also with like lineage
and yeah Evolution
just just because it's not like
practical in today's date because it's
really unpractical when you think about
it because of the evolution of birth
control do you know what I'm saying like
you know and I think most guys like want
wives right like they want to get
married at some point and stuff and I
think
um now the average age of first marriage
is 27 where like they used to marry and
it's 31 in the UK actually it's like
higher yeah for women so I think you
know men would almost like a lot of
times like to not care but I don't think
you can undo their like biology yeah I
was gonna say like it's not like it
wouldn't be a deciding factor I don't
think depends how far in I was in terms
of like how far along we were yeah but
if I'm gonna sit here and pretend that
it does isn't like if I met a girl and
she was like oh she slept with like a
hundred guys I'm not going to pretend
that wouldn't at least impact oh is she
like girlfriend wifey material yeah
because obviously like you said like
guys
the kind of woman that guys want to take
seriously is the kind of woman who is
sexually selective
and if a girl comes across to a guy that
she's not that selective then it just
makes him think I don't know there's
like there's like an instinctual kind of
thing that's like
you don't trust her judgment yeah yeah
well you don't trust her pulse judgment
yeah
however so full disclaimer I've been in
a whole season and casual for the past
year because I have been really
codependent I was for all my sexual life
I was very codependent very exclusive I
only slept with like one person at a
time and then I got to a point where I
was like so life is not black and white
so I was either like right I'm single
and I'm not dating I'm not sleeping with
anyone or I'm looking for a relationship
and I was like wait there's this Middle
Ground intersection that is like oh
casual dating or casual sex and I was
like right as long as I'm being honest
I'm feeling respected I'm not lying to
anyone
um but then it got to a point where it
was like
because men knew that other men were
interested in me they were like well
wait a minute she's desirable and I was
like oh okay and then you kind of become
it becomes quite powerful it almost felt
like like I say well I didn't I think
men are more competitive right so yeah
yeah
so
um I I have jokingly had like a roster
because I'm like right all these men
that I've been casually seeing have told
me you're not gonna be my girlfriend
don't get attached I'm like Okay cool so
what I'll do is I'll make sure do you
not get attached actually
um uh well I am yeah I'm cognizant
enough to be respectful and to know that
if you tell me I'm not going to change
your mind I'm not going to change you
yeah
um so I'm like okay so I'll I'll okay
I'll make sure then that I'm dating
other people so if one of you ends it or
pisses me off or isn't available or you
know I'll just sort of start to do this
cycle so it's almost like you have more
almost like a defense mechanism so you
don't get your feelings hurt yeah like
my attachment I don't know what my
attachment style is it's probably like
very anxious but if I then I'm I'm a
really open book I don't lie to anyone
I'm very much like okay well if I'm
dating you I'm also dating other people
but all of these guys who have told me
outright Amy you're not going to be my
girlfriend I'm not gonna be serious
about you don't get feelings to me I'm
like okay so to make sure I'm respecting
what you've said I'm dating other people
to not get feelings to not get right
they get really upset about it yeah they
get really like the ego situation and
I'm like but I'm confused I'm confused
by that like but they still don't want
to date you they want to date me but
they don't be serious no like like an
actual boyfriend girlfriend yeah yeah
they still don't want that they they
like the it's more like they like the
idea of me but not the reality or you
know there's something that's just not
quite there and I'm like that's fine we
can have fun but I'm gonna have fun with
other people yeah I can benefit from the
other thing that like we're kind of
going against our biology when we try to
do that oh probably yeah well I don't
want kids so that really like
it really [ __ ] people up sorry if I'm
not allowed to like cuss but um it
really [ __ ] like a lot of men are like
you're wrong and I'm like no I I don't
want kids and that's really anti like
biology and evolution but I'm like no I
don't I don't well at least for now I
don't want yeah what makes you if you
were infertile tomorrow would that like
make you sad or would you not care no I
wouldn't care at this point in my life
yeah because I'd be like well if I want
kids there's a lot of ways to get kids
um but I think I am at a point where I'm
like I am still baby I honestly feel
like I only started Living last year
when I turned 26. and I want to be
selfish I want to be financially secure
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible